لليوم الثاني على التوالي يتكرر المشهد
الفوضوي وحاله الجمود التي باتت تخيم على
مجلس النواب الامريكي بعد جولات تلو
الاخرى من التصويت الانتخابي رئيسا للمجلس
دون جدوى كاد المكار في المرشح الابرز
لهذا المنصب فشل في كل تلك الجوالات على
الحصول على الاصوات اللازمه التي تاهله
بان يتسلم رئاسه مجلس النواب في مواجهه
مجموعه معارضه صغيره من الجمهوريين
المحسوبين على اليمين مجموعه وصفت بانها
مجموعه من المتمردين مشهد لم تشهده
الولايات المتحده من دون نحو مئه عام هذا
كله حدا الرئيس السابق لاني يدخل ويلقي
بدعمه من جديد لمقارتي لكن دون جدوى هذا
الوضع في مجلس النواب يجمد عمل المجلس
بحيث لا يمكن همم تسير اي من اعمالها
التشريعيه من حيث طرح التشريعات تشكيل
اللجان عقد جلسات الاجتماع وحتى في وقت
لاحق ان استمر دفع رواتب الموظفين طبعا
هذا الوضع وصف بانه مشهد محرج وبتوازي معه
كان هناك العديد من المحادثات الجانبيه
بين عده اطراف داخل الحزب الجمهوري في
مصعا لحل حالات هذه الازمه خصوصا وان
الجمهوريين وخصوصا الداعمين لمكارسي
يقولون انما يحدث فعليا يعطل المجلس ويعطل
ماوك ما اوكله او اكل به اولئك المشرعين
من قبل الناخبين وهو تنفيذ الاجنده
التشريعيه
ما هذا كله يقع ويجلس الديمقراطيون في
مقعد المراقب والمتفرج والا احيانا حتى
سعيد لحاله الفوضى هذا التي
دفعت الجانب الاخر من غرفه مجلس النواب
الامريكي